الان صواريخ المقاومه تنطلق من هنا من
شمال قطاع غزه كما
نشاهد الان صواريخ المقاومه تنطلق من هنا
من شمال قطاع غزه كما
نشاهد
اعود لك الياس اذا الصور كانت لمشاهد من
متابعات الناس ايضا مشاهده الناس في شمال
قطاع غزه لخروج الصواريخ من هذه المنطقه
سرايا القدس في السياق كانت تعلن قبل قليل
انها استهدفت نير عام و سيدي روت ما هو
المتوفر معلومات عن ذلك ايضا اذا كانت
سفرات الانذار دوت في مناطق اخرى
الياس
بالفعل محمد وهذا القصف الصاروخي ياتي رغم
كل ما تشاهده الان عبر الشاشه من عندنا
هنا في غلاف غزه هذه الحرائق المنبعثه وال
اعمده الدخان المنبعثه في كل مكان تقريبا
في مدينه غزه واحيائها وحتى المناطق
الشماليه في جباليا ومخيمها وجباليا البلد
وبيت حنون وبيت لاهيه كل هذه المناطق
مشتعله لكن رغم ذلك واضح بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ما زالت تملك القدره على توجيه
هذه الضربات الصاروخيه لمنطقه غلاف غزه
قبل دقائق معدوده دوت صافرات الانذار ايضا
في سديروت وايفين ونير عام واستهدفت هذه
المناطق بدفعه من الصواريخ نحن ننتظر فيما
اذا كانت هنالك اي بلاغات من جانب الاسعاف
الاسرائيلي حول هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه لكن
الواضح انه قبل ذلك بقليل كانت هنالك ايضا
دفعه صاروخيه استهدفت هذه المره منطقه
عسقلان مدينه عسقلان المدينه برمتها كانت
تحت القصف بالاضافه الى المناطق الواقعه
الى الشمالي من قطاع غزه كانتيف عسرا وزكي
ومفك عيم وغيرها من البلدات الاسرائيليه
في منطقه غلاف غزه الشمالي وهذا ياتي رغم
كما قلنا محمد كل هذا الض كل هذه الضربات
المدفعيه والجويه على قطاع غزه واضح بان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ باتجاه غلاف غزه
وراينا ايضا في خضم الاسابيع وا او او
الايام الماضيه ان لدى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ايضا القدره عندما تريد على
توجيه ضربات صاروخيه حتى الى العمق
الاسرائيلي حتى الى مدينه تلي ابيب
وضواحيها الجنوبيه والشرقيه وحتى الشماليه
اي الان ال المصادر التي تتحدث من عسقلان
حول الضرب الصاروخيه تشير الى ان سته
صواريخ على الاقل تم اطلاقها باتجاه
المدينه جرى اعتراض بعضها في سماء المدينه
ولكن الاسعاف الاسرائيلي لم يعلن حتى الان
عن وقوع اي اصابات في صفوف الاسرائيليه